once upon a time in Hollywood is out and
as of this taping is certified fresh' at
91% making Tarantino 9 for 9 in fresh
films for his entire directorial
filmography 8 of which are certified
fresh films but how does this one stack
against your favorite Tarantino film
will it be top 5 even top 3 let's find
out hey everyone I'm Mark Ellis welcome
to the after show and boy what a program
we have for you today we're talking
about Once Upon a Time in Hollywood so
if you've not yet seen that movie fair
warning there are spoilers that lay
ahead I am thrilled to be joined by an
all-time great panel first off she is an
editor Rotten Tomatoes miss Jacqueline
Kohli is back-to-back and very late 60s
attire I really did wear my once upon a
time in Hollywood outfit just for you
and she is a geek bomb host you know you
ever miss mod and last but certainly not
least Scott movie's release dates
himself man how are you buddy I'll do it
great come on we're gonna talk about
once upon a time in Hollywood this could
be a very interesting conversation yeah
that's what I love about Tarantino
movies is whether you love them whether
you hate them there's always something
to talk about afterwards so before we
get into our individual topics I want to
throw it to the panel is this a fresh
movie is this a rotten movie Scott kick
us off it's fresh but with reservations
it's a movie that I needed to stew on I
needed to sleep on it I woke up the next
morning ultimately I had a lot more fun
watching it than I did thinking about it
after it was over all right lord Garrett
we're staying on the couch are you going
fresh or rotten I had the opposite
effect during it I was just like wow
this is a long movie but afterwards I
was like okay I'm starting to get it but
even though it was visually stunning and
I loved the acting in it I just felt the
lack of story and points leave this
movie rotten for me oh all right tied at
one Jacqueline break the time um
fresh ish that's I mean that's kind of
where I land with it I'm kind of like
you I have some reservations or as I say
it has some problems in fact some may
say it's problematic at times but I had
the opposite whereas in when I was
watching it I was enjoying it but didn't
really have a lot to think about it but
the
when I thought about it later I ended up
appreciating it more and I actually saw
the craft and what he did and also I had
the benefit of a second meeting outside
of the grand spectacle that is the Film
Festival that I saw it the first time so
I would say about Jacqueline she's been
to more film festivals than Dom Perignon
I've got the same way where I am fresh
ish with it I I think it is a fresh
movie but when you get into our first
topic here is this the Tarantino film
that we expected because I think there's
an enjoyment that we all had with the
film but it does get very sticky at
other points so let me start here with
you is this the Tarantino movie that you
expected it to be no and I think that
that's I also I almost liked that about
it but I think we've got such a
preconceived notion of what a Tarantino
esque film is that we were like almost
applying it whilst watching it and being
like this doesn't feel like it's
supposed to as a Tarantino movie until
the last 15 minutes you know when you've
got the extreme violence and the gore
and like you know at the point of the
movie and then you're like oh god oh god
this is what I waited for but I think
that yeah going into it you really have
to it actually felt like a Richard
Linklater movie to me especially the
everybody everybody gets some I believe
is like everybody wants some want some
they don't get it but they want it and
you know that was like an explorative
story about you know the 70s of college
kids going to you know practice baseball
and here I felt it's the same way but
it's 1969 in Hollywood and you kind of
have a voyeuristic look at it all and
that's all great but then you just go
cool what was but why
and you can't did the fact that you know
the whole time while watching this maybe
I kept going why why I don't want to
have that question throughout it I could
not agree more with that assessment
right there see once upon a time in
Hollywood like while I was watching the
film it was immersive I was into it the
scenes and some of the scenes are shot
and complete takes I that style is
Tarantino's signature and on that level
he did deliver but here's a filmmaker
who is like deep in pop-culture
references who was a massive massive
movie fan and he's making a movie about
movies about TV as well about Hollywood
in 1969 this should be like his
playground
I found that to be strangely reserved
restrained in that respect yeah
like it felt like this should have been
the most Tarantino ish movie he's ever
done and it felt like the least
Tarantino ish movie he's ever done and
the scenes that that he's that he's shy
are really great but the whole feels
like it's less than the sum of its parts
and the payoff did not work for me well
it's that payoff that I think a lot of
people Jacqueline are saying well that
does feel like Tarantino because it's
like he was restraining himself for two
and a half hours and then we got all
that violence that core that's switching
up of what actually happened in a
historical period of time so up until
then I'm hearing a lot of people say
that he actually made this his most
mature work in his most personal work
maybe because you didn't get as many
Tarantino isms leading up to that climax
yeah I kind of just have the opposite
the why for this film was very easy for
me the the thing I was more grappling
with is the execution the why is really
simple I think Quentin Tarantino is
having a reflection upon his career and
he's looking at what he's done and if
you look at his first eight films
there's a lot of like high-hat cymbal
there's a lot of like brooch this is
really just his very slow
it's his Bob Dylan the way make you feel
my love love song like this is just a
quiet meditation on what he I think is
talking about which is the death of
cinema which is the death of the type of
cinema that he proclaims to be the
theatrical original story cinema that
was based a lot in you know Asian
filmmakers and 70s filmmakers and and
blaxploitation and B films and he turned
that up to a notch and applied those
elements into his filmmaking and that
was what Quentin Tarantino is this is
him saying this is what got me here and
it's dying and I'm kind of gonna have
one last hurrah with it so for me it
totally made sense on the why and I
loved him for what he was doing with it
I just wish he would have found a better
way to maybe stitch all of these things
together okay so we're talking about the
ending of the film so if you seen an
inglorious basterds
you know the Quentin Tarantino has no
problem doing his own version of history
but the ending of inglorious basterds
worked
so much better here you have inglourious
basterds World War 2 movie and you have
the creator of the Holocaust getting
shot in the face by a bunch of Jews ok
that's a great payoff and it was
unexpected well this one you have the
dead Hollywood saving the Hollywood that
he wanted to keep making lives with
Sharon Tate I get that I get that
Jacqueline but the payoff in this movie
is that the Manson followers go to the
house to kill you know Sharon Tate and
they they go into a different house and
a big big spoiler Brad Pitt kicks the
crap out of them why high off his LSD it
was laced into a cigarette that was
given to him by one of the Manson
followers so they never even made it
next door to kill Sharon Tate so
basically Sharon Tate lives and while
all this is going on Leo's character is
in the pool listening to his headphones
he wasn't even a part of that climactic
scene and he kicked it off but but not
but that the payoff of this I felt like
what was the point of this so I actually
have a little bit of inside information
on the echo part so when I interviewed
the cast and Quentin Tarantino about the
movie and this was the first time that
they were kind of all sitting down and
having a private discussion and I was
like looking at the ceiling while
listening to every word and Tarun
Tarantino was saying that still at that
point of time he wanted to re-edit the
last 15 minutes of the movie he wanted
to change it because they think there is
another version out there where even in
the trailer there's a scene where Sharon
Tate's swimming in a swimming pool we
never see that in the movie there is
hours of footage that he has not used
any and he found it incredibly difficult
to get it to 2 hours and 41 minutes but
he still has an alternative alternative
ending to this movie and I think that
that's super interesting as well what
would this movie look like if it didn't
have that last 15 min well that last
five to you I think that last 15 minutes
gave us a lot of great moments to kind
of say oh well maybe that rescued my
experience of the movie or maybe that
accentuated what I was already enjoying
but just in terms of Tarantino and him
as a filmmaker this is he always
threatens he's gonna retire always says
this is my last movie let's say he makes
a tenth film do you want to see him
return to form with the classic
Tarantino that we grew up loving or do
you want to see him continue to
expand his horizons you know what to go
back to jacqueline's point I do see that
there is a maturity to his work in this
because he doesn't fall prey to the
tropes that he created he doesn't fall
back onto his own cliches it's like he
wanted to make something different and
again you see the restraint there with
regards to to that but you see the bold
ambition with regards to the way he shot
certain scenes there are some really
really great scenes in this movie like
when when Brad Pitt's character goes out
to the ranch and he has a scene with the
Manson followers that I thought was
going to go into Midsomer territory I
didn't think he was gonna make it out of
there I thought it was a goner but he
wasn't and I think that was a brilliant
move though the gap made the scene even
better right it was intense
it definitely was intense and again this
is one of the scenes that I was very
much engaged to and I was into and I was
immersed to when I was completely
transfixed by what I was watching but
when I thought about the way the movie
was pieced together after the fact
leading up to an underwhelming payoff
again it didn't add up but I also loved
that the scenes where he seemed Leonardo
DiCaprio's character struggled with his
stutter struggle with trying to neo his
scenes there's a scene done and one take
for a shooting a scene with Timothy
Olyphant
and Tarantino did a great job shooting
that scene but like what's the story
here that and I think you know the
concept that he is nurturing has been
painted on the whole thing with like a
broad stroke but you're saying like that
it felt a little disjointed and it
needed to kind of go together that that
thing that's missing is an overarching
storyline you know I think it's more
explicit on what he's trying to say he
wouldn't need a storyline if he was just
a little bit more explicit on what he
was doing I think some of it got lost in
the sauce you know what I'm saying like
like I think you guys just don't need a
story though I mean I don't know
sometimes there's there's a lot of
movies that I like that are not
necessarily plotless but there's not
like a huge a to B factor or ones that
have a very simplistic story like Mad
Max where it's like just change or go
back like a little more substance or a
little more flat but I think regardless
what if you look at Tarantino as a
filmmaker he is the star of his own
movie
right but this movie in particular we
got two huge movie stars and this is
actually the first time that we saw Brad
Pitt Leonardo DiCaprio pair up together
on camera they did a Martin Scorsese
short in 2015 but they never shared
scenes together so this is the first
time I got to experience them together I
thought that pair was tremendous I was
one of the highlights of the film for me
so Scott manse Brad and Lily yeah Brad
Pitt and Liana DiCaprio were terrific
together they great chemistry
and the great thing about it was and
this was unexpected for in Tarantino
film is that they were very endearing
they were great friends they had each
other's backs I felt a lot of empathy
for both of these characters especially
in oral DiCaprio's character because of
just the way he was starting to feel
insecure like it has been a lot more
empathy than we've seen in the other
Tarantino films so that was surprising
to me in a good way but the two of them
together did not disappoint that went
above and beyond I thought they were
awesome I'm personally a little bit
shocked I could almost feel Quentin
chomping at the bit to just jump in the
scene and act alongside these people but
obviously you got to let those guys have
their moments because they were
brilliant together they were the
highlights and Lena Leonardo was
actually saying that he felt that his
character was so relatable and that even
though that was a big part of 1969 in
Hollywood he still feels that that
applies today where it's like you
constantly have to remain relevant you
have to be hard-working you have to you
know you know there are people that you
can just instantly dismiss you and he
has a fear of that in real life and you
can tell that that's I think he applied
it so well was this worth the hype as
far as the build-up of the two stars
pairing together for the first time I
mean I think it was great I mean you're
gonna get to the biggest movie stars on
the planet and I think they both perform
very admirably I think they're gonna
both remain in the conversation going
forward as far as awards but I don't
know if they're gonna go as far as maybe
a lot of people watching the movie would
hope I've already seen at least
personally seen three performances in
both supporting and lead actor that
would top what they did up there and
they did a phenomenal job but because
it's Brad Pitt and Leo I have a feeling
they make make it far and one of them
may snatch a trophy undeservedly
well we're DiCaprio this is his first
movie since he won the
for Best Actor for the revenue and four
years off four years off now Leo
DiCaprio is not a kind of actor who
makes like one or two movies a year but
when he makes a movie you know it's
gonna be good and I thought that as the
film progressed I felt like Leo really
really delivered unlike any way we've
seen him before I mean playing an actor
who is trying to he's having an identity
crisis you know he's having a career
crisis and Tarantino himself had said in
other interviews that he sort of loosely
based Leo's character a TV star trying
to transition to films or even just hold
on to a stature he loosely based Leo's
character on William Shatner I thought
it was better announced well maybe he
was oh but he talked a lot about how
after Star Trek you know he he really
had a hard time chatting at the Bell
he's doing just a lot of different
things just to like make a living but he
was really struggling until Star Trek
the motion picture which mr. Roberge
release dates came out 40 years ago this
year that's very true maybe someday
Leo's character Rick Dalton will be in
priceline.com
Jack I want to start with you when we
talk about other maybe supporting roles
that really spoke to you thoughts maybe
you were saw some missed opportunities
up there like for instance Margot Robbie
as Sharon Tate honestly I thought the
Margot Robbie as Sharon Tate role was
fine I think people are making a bigger
deal about it because it's Margot Robbie
like if he would have cast any
up-and-coming blonde actress who could
portray Sharon Tate's innocence people
wouldn't focus this hard on it but
because it's Margot Robbie
oscar-nominated actress who's in some of
the biggest films out there right now
people were expecting to have this huge
role I think it was great cuz she was
representing this Hollywood this this
love affair the Golden Age of Hollywood
which with Quentin Tarantino clearly
loves he Revere's this type of film
making these filmmakers so she
represents that and so I think you have
to give somebody like Margo that so I
loved what she did also shout-out to
Annie McDowell's daughter who played the
hippie girl yes for the tiger
yeah yeah and like that's grown out a
little ink to help but that's definitely
growing out she committed for that role
so yeah I thought she was really great
it was got to see Kurt Russell Al Pacino
had bit party a lot of nice little
classic moments here for sure and I
think a lot of people are pointing
towards that last 15 minutes of the film
as like for it like Rick getting the
flamethrower I was one of my personal
favorites ma did he have any any any
all-time classic Tarantino moments he
would put up there against the best that
we've seen from Quentin actually yes we
do you think that you know the gore and
the extreme kind of like actions that
take place are the quintessential
classic moments for me personally my
favorite classic moment was the
attention to detail that Quentin
Tarantino allowed whilst Brad was
driving throughout LA and the scenes
that took place were just so beautiful
because he really did transform
Hollywood to 1969 so on the freeways all
the highways going through the canyons
going on Hollywood Boulevard where it's
like you know you would look outside and
you would see like everything the facade
of all these buildings were so 1969 and
I was in awe of what he did with that no
dialogue going from A to B quite
literally but that driving scene for me
did it I was in awe of that when it
happened because I happen to be stuck in
traffic on Vine going up towards
Hollywood and I saw two old school cars
going by and I'm like Jacqueline I love
the scene where Leo is kind of giving
himself a pep talk to when he goes in
and he's Deniz he's frustrated with the
last scene that he just did he wants to
be better that whole trailer meltdown I
thought was one of the highlights of the
entire movie yeah it's great because it
illustrates I think what people forget
about these artists it's like drunk
office whatever he's still gonna try and
do the best job and I think for me the
even better scene because of that first
scene is Winnie then and goes and nails
that next one like I like that scene way
better because I think it just proves
like even on the dregs of his career as
he's starting to become less and less
relevant
he's still able to like turn it out and
like give you a star type acting scene
because he has that talent it's just
buried underneath booze and self-doubt
and I don't know what the hell that
stutter thing was but all this stuff
that he had in the movie but yeah do you
think that was like another way that
Quentin Tarantino is saying that that's
been lost in filmmaking actors actually
bringing it even with all the discourse
of their struggles they still want to be
the best actor that they can be and
bring it where a lot of the times I
don't know if people kind of just do the
job and then call it an yeah because
that was no longer about getting a
paycheck for Rick that was about proving
that he still can do this and I think
one of the reasons for that Scott is
that he was challenged by his very young
co-star he saw what a professional she
was that was another one my favorite
scenes was just meeting this young actor
reading the book and she's just kind of
telling Rick how it is that was a great
scene there again there are a lot of
really really great scenes the scene
with with Leo where he's Pepin himself
up and he wants to go back and do the
scene again and there's it's that
there's all the one take the other scene
of surprise no one's talked about this
yet Brad Cate versus Bruce Lee Brad kid
kicks the crap out of Bruce Lee throws
him against the car gets the side of the
car I mean it was a I know like I think
most of it was like one take that was
vintage Tarantino that was a fun laugh
but the Brad Pitt kicking somebody's
butt that I more preferred was at the
end I mean again you have the Manson
murders that we think are about to take
place and instead a stuntman steps up
and it will a him and his dogs
pretty great count Brandi he is amazing
I will say though I did not like that
Bruce Lee scene know I was into the
Bruce Lee I think I just didn't like it
I am very interested to see what you
know the estate of Bruce Lee and Bruce
Lee fan of make of it and they kind of
made him into be a bit of a bully I get
its that tire or whatever but it just
yeah it felt a little out of place for
me I had to think about that as well
with like applying Y onto it I was like
what was that all about why did that
happen
but it was because he ran out of you
know that this is why he's a struggling
stuntman and this is why he's so loyal
to leo is because he goes on set and he
has absolutely no regard or no decorum
and he is yeah he just throws someone
into a
so he's wrecking property and he's
damaging her an ego thanks the dichotomy
that's on set he's just got blatant
disregard for it and I was like got it
that has then furthered kind of like the
understanding of why he needs Rick
Dalton so much and I was like okay got
it but you're right it was a little bit
like that's the only scene that he got
really and you kind of like oh I mean
they could have just referenced it that
was it
I mentioned the top of the show
Tarantino is batting a thousand when it
comes to fresh films eight of his nine
or certified fresh' so where does this
rank for y'all is this creeping into the
top five for anyone early no no wow no
one I see I saw personally I think in
glorious past yes is his best movie then
Pulp Fiction then retro part dogs then
Kill Bill 1 and 2 then Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood ok so it's it's it's on the
cut line there it's better than Django
Unchained to me it's better than Jackie
Brown da no Jack Cole you're a rebuttal
Jackie Browns my number one movie I'll
do that I'd say it's probably like seven
okay seven seven out of nine more them
too yeah okay yeah yeah okay I feel
completely justified in my rotten in
your favorite Quinn Tarantino movie of
all time on this made me miss pulp
fiction I'm any mid-70s not the sixties
yeah oh I put this in the bottom half of
it I'd say it's maybe like six or seven
I think that I enjoyed this a lot more
than hateful eight and so I think there
were you know we got a little more juice
in this movies whatever Quentin
Tarantino decides to do next we'll
probably talk about it on a future after
show that does it for us here today
thank you all so much for tuning in hey
make sure you hit that subscribe button
so you never miss another after show you
can also hit that Bell that's gonna give
you an alert every time we drop a new
one we love talking about big movies
with the also comment right now let us
know your thoughts on Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood is it your favorite
Tarantino movie of all time is that your
most anticipated Tarantino movie to date
we love hearing from you for my
incredible panelists here I am Mark
Ellis and we'll see y'all at the next
discussion
[Music]
you
[Music]